LILLY MCNEALUS: Hi.
My name is Lilly McNealus.
I'm the head of outbound
product management
and strategy for Vertex
AI at Google Cloud.
Thank you for
joining us at Next.
Today, we're going to talk
about how Vertex AI is now
even easier for developers and
how these advancements help
enterprises to
deploy more models,
gain valuable business
insights, and fully realize
the value of their
ML investments.
I'm thrilled that later
in today's session,
I'll be joined by Matt
Ferrari of Wayfair
and Jaime Espinoza
of Twitter to discuss
how each of their
organizations have embraced
Vertex AI to solve
significant challenges
and evolve their machine
learning strategies.
First, let's set the
scene for the reality
that most organizations
are facing today with AI.
Customers tell us, and analysts
confirm, that almost half
of ML models built never
make it into production.
When organizations
aren't able to deploy
their models their
hardworking teams have built,
they can't realize the full
value of their AI investments.
This results in low ROI
and a lack of willingness
to continue investing
in AI strategies
from senior leadership.
This leads to
missed opportunities
to actually use insights from
AI to inform business decision
and wastes high-value
talent that can actually
lead to retention issues in this
very competitive job market.
So what can organizations do to
increase the number of models
in deployment and actually see a
return on their AI investments?
According to McKinsey's 2020
"The State of AI" report,
AI high performers, though
seeing meaningful return,
have standardized machine
learning platforms
for all stages of data science,
data engineering, and machine
learning workloads.
Organizations who adopt
end-to-end in-house AI
platforms are more
likely to be successful
in their implementation
of machine learning
to ease deployment
and to realize
the value of their
investments more quickly.
So how is Google
helping customers
navigate AI transformations
and avoid common pitfalls?
Google's commitment to
our customers' success
means that we are investing
in three focus areas
to ease ML deployment
in the enterprise.
First, platform centralization
and unification,
bringing together the best
of Google's AI development
and deployment tools
into a single unified
workflow for our customers--
Second, accelerating
time to value--
our MLOps tooling allows
you to monitor and adjust
your deployed models faster
and with better insights.
Additionally, we're
bringing to market
a suite of AI solutions built
to address the most common use
cases.
And lastly, trust
and responsibility--
we're continuing to lead in
responsible AI and building
tools to empower our
customers to do the same.
So let's dig into platform
centralization and unification
a little bit.
Google Cloud offers
a unified ecosystem
of data and AI
capabilities designed
to make it easy for
everyone to innovate.
We connect the different
types of data processing,
from plan-at-scale OLTP systems
to analytics to data lakes
to data science to
business analytics.
We connect the different
roles that work with data
and provide them a common
platform to build upon.
We enable an ecosystem of
external data, partner,
and open source systems.
And finally, we bring all
this together with Vertex AI,
a standardized
end-to-end workflow,
to allow customers to truly
realize the value of their data
through AI.
You may remember
that at Google I/O
this year, less than
five months ago,
we announced Vertex AI, which
is a unified AI platform.
Vertex AI creates the
connections in the data science
workflow from a
technical standpoint
to fast-track the
path to ML innovation
through collaboration,
automation
of mundane or redundant
tasks, and by integrating
deployment and management
tools to streamline MLOps.
The very premise
of Vertex AI was
to unify Google's ML tool set
and to make experimentation
process faster,
accelerate deployment,
and to simplify model management
with our MLOps features.
We've seen real traction in
customer adoption of Vertex AI.
In comparison to previous
versions of our AI platforms
available for over
five years, we
have seen the following areas
of growth between Vertex AI's
general availability
being announced
in May 2021 and August 2021.
The total volume of APIs on
our platform has tripled.
The volume of Vertex
AI training has
increased by 1 and 1/2 times.
And the volume of predictions
on our entire platform
has doubled since Vertex
AI was announced in May.
This also has seen-- we've also
seen a 2X increase in GPU hours
for predictions.
We have delivered on our promise
to serve more predictions
and deploy more
models with Vertex AI.
We know enterprises are often
concerned that increasingly
centralized workflows could
come at the cost of governance
and compliance issues.
Google addresses
this by building
Vertex AI with security and
compliance features built in.
Many of those features,
highlighted in green,
that you see on the slide
were in preview in May.
And we're excited
to share with you
that they will be reaching
general availability
within the coming weeks.
We wanted to highlight a
few of these for you today.
Vertex AI Metadata tracks the
inputs and outputs of an ML
pipeline, as well as the
lineage of artifacts,
which can play a critical role
in debugging and compliance.
Once your model
is in production,
Vertex AI model Monitoring
alerts your data scientists
to data drift for items which
may need their supervision.
This enhances the compliance
and audibility of models.
Vertex AI Pipelines
are reusable pipelines
that help data scientists share
components and iterate quickly.
Vertex Pipelines are
built with a Python SDK
so you can author both KFP
and TFX pipelines with ease.
Our Pipelines
service is completely
serverless, allowing you to
scale up or down as you need
it-- as you need to
without having to worry
about managing infrastructure.
ML engineers are already
using Vertex AI Pipelines
to move faster from
prototype to production
and to further
accelerate time to value.
For more advanced
workloads, enterprises
can now use Vertex AI
Neural Architecture Search
to optimize neural networks.
And they can use our Vertex
AI Matching Engine service,
which gives the ability to
quickly and efficiently look up
nearest neighbor embeddings
for recommendations and search
need-- without the need
for human intervention.
Data science is a
transformational investment
for many customers
and has continued
to evolve as AI and
data have become
even more tightly integrated
in the enterprise.
Customers want
seamless experiences
across business units and want a
unified data and ML experience.
So today, we're
pleased to announce
a public preview of our
Vertex AI Workbench,
a natural evolution of
Google's Notebook offerings
to respond to the ever-changing
needs of our customers.
Vertex AI Workbench is a single
environment for data scientists
to complete all
of their ML work,
from experimentation to
deployment to managing
and monitoring models.
It is a Jupyter-based,
fully managed,
scalable, enterprise-ready
compute infrastructure
with easily enforceable
policies and user management.
With Vertex AI Workbench, data
analysts, data scientists,
and all data and
AI practitioners
can analyze all of their data,
from BigQuery, Dataproc, Spark,
Looker, and Vertex AI,
all in one interface.
Vertex AI Workbench
facilitates data
to training at scale
with fewer lines of code
and easy connectivity
to our MLOps services
to improve model survivability
at the critical hand-off point
to ML engineers.
Using Vertex AI
Workbench, you can
implement your continuous
integration, training,
and deployment workflows.
Additionally, through our
partnership with NVIDIA,
developers will have the ability
to deploy Vertex AI Workbench
notebooks from NVIDIA
NGC with a single click.
NVIDIA's NGC is a hub for
GPU-optimized AI software,
including frameworks, models,
SDKs, and Jupyter Notebooks.
A number of our
customers are already
using Vertex AI Workbench
to ease ML deployment
and support their
company's transformations.
So we're thrilled to include
two of these customers
to share their stories with
us today, Twitter and Wayfair.
Matt and Jaime,
please, could you
introduce yourselves
and share more
about your organizations
and your ML strategies?
MATT FERRARI: Sure.
Well, thank you, Lilly.
My name is Matt Ferrari.
I lead our MarTech and data
and ML platforms organizations,
both on the product and
the engineering side.
In terms of Wayfair, we're one
of the world's largest home
retailers.
We serve just over 31
million active customers.
And we have over 22
million products.
But often, from
the outside, we're
seen as a retailer or
a home goods company.
The truth is we're much more.
We have a very
robust platform, one
that scales across
many countries
and is really steeped in
big data, ML, microservices,
and many other
technologies that we're
going to talk about today,
all in the spirit of bringing
world-class service
to our customers.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Awesome.
And Jaime, can you share
a little about yourself?
JAIME ESPINOSA: Thank you.
Twitter-- I'm the lead
PM for productizing ML.
My team is called Cortex.
It's tasked with accelerating
the development of machine
learning across all of Twitter.
We do this through
research, applied ML,
and we provide an
end-to-end platform
on which all of the
ML at the company
is created, from ideation all
the way into productization.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Great.
Matt, could you tell
us a little bit more
about your cloud journey and the
partnership with Google Cloud?
And what were the
key decision factors
that you contemplated when
making the decision to partner
with Google Cloud?
MATT FERRARI: Sure.
Wayfair started down the path
with GCP a few years ago,
was an early adopter across
multiple GCP services,
ranging from Kubernetes
to BigQuery to Dataproc.
And we were already partners
with Google for our advertising
business.
But what we really looked
at when we thought about GCP
was an AI-driven
organization that's
also a major player in
the open source community
and a thought leader
in the ML space.
And so we saw Google as
a true technology partner
and, specifically, were
driven to their openness
to provide feedback in helping
influence GCP's roadmap.
Beyond AI, the
underlying products,
such as BigQuery, Dataproc,
and now Vertex AI,
are examples of that.
And it's just the beginning
of Wayfair diving into things
like data velocity, quality,
and data engineering
as it applies to
machine learning.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Awesome.
And Jaime, could
you please tell us
more about your transformational
priorities for machine
learning at Twitter and how
GCP is helping you reach
those transformational goals?
JAIME ESPINOSA: Thanks.
Across Twitter,
there are many teams
that are working together.
And because of the complexity
and the scale at which we're
operating, there are
many opportunities
to leverage machine learning.
Our ML platform powers every
stage of the ML project,
from experimentation all
the way into productization
and the maintenance, the MLOps.
It is ultimately
a hybrid system.
It's only able to be built
because of the partnership
that we have with GCP.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Amazing.
And Matt, what use cases
or business problems were
you looking to solve when you
started working with Google
Cloud and adopting Vertex AI?
MATT FERRARI: Sure.
We envisioned a lot of
use cases at Wayfair.
They started in marketing and
search and recommendations.
Think about, how can
we make sure you're
searching for the right product
and then recommendations moving
forward?
We thought about product
catalog, supply chain, and even
end-to-end customer service.
And we thought all of that can
benefit from machine learning
and, in turn, Vertex AI.
In fact, even though it's still
early phases of that journey,
there's already parts
of that ML lifecycle
that really sing that today.
For example, really, we
built it on the principles
of how do we make ML
at Wayfair easier.
That means-- examples would
be how do we accelerate time
to value for new models by
reducing the model training
duration of each
development iteration.
We also thought about
how do we reduce friction
while we're building and
deploying models at scale
while still increasing
reliability and speed of how
do we retrain jobs to make sure
that data scientists can focus
on data science work.
And then we really
focused on how do we
enable ML in the
fabric of how we make
decisions for the business.
So how do we intertwine it
into our strategic objectives
across Wayfair?
And our early results
have been really positive.
The truth is that we have a lot
of very large model training
jobs that are between 5 and
10 times faster at this point.
And we've gotten feedback
from our data scientists
that they specifically like all
of the hyperparameter tuning
available to them.
LILLY MCNEALUS:
And on that point,
what is the-- what is most
important to you and your data
scientists when you focus on
deploying ML models at scale?
MATT FERRARI: Sure.
So I would tell you
that before, it would--
if I interviewed them, they
would say it was really around
data quality and duplication
of data or lack of integrity
of data--
came out, I don't trust the
data or I have data sprawl
everywhere.
And what we really
focused on there
is how do we drive time to
value for new models and model
enhancements, how do we focus
on quality of predictions that
drive business impact,
and then, finally,
how do we automate
as much as possible
in a post-deployment model
from a monitoring and tuning
perspective.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Awesome.
And I'm curious, Jaime, what
is most important to you
and your data scientists
when you focus on deploying
ML models at scale at Twitter?
JAIME ESPINOSA: Because Twitter
has a unique and incredible
impact on the world--
maybe because of this fact--
and we are growing very fast.
As Twitter grows, so does
the diversity of the talent
that that brings in, and so
does the diversity of thought.
The diversity of
techniques and tools
is actually very
important for us
to maintain in order
to be fair as--
and to learn from each other.
Twitter offers, also,
a unique opportunity
to work deeply across
multiple ML fields.
This also translates into how
we represent data, how we--
what kinds of system
requirements we have.
We have found that
flexibility is really
the key to empower our talent.
I think it's very common
for us, for anybody--
that we are trained with
particular type of tools
and techniques.
And these are the
things that makes--
that we're very
familiar with, and is
what makes us the
most productive.
And being able to provide
this within the ML platform,
we have found, is the best
way to enable everybody
to be as productive as possible.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Great.
And you just mentioned a few.
But are there any
other key learnings
that you would like to share
with other organizations
that you've come
across as you continue
to scale to the magnitude
you're currently operating at?
JAIME ESPINOSA: And so a--
I'll first give you
a sense for scale.
Twitter operates at
a mind-blowing scale
and a mind-blowing speed.
And these are requirements that
continue to grow very steadily.
I'll share-- over my career,
I've worked in about--
in eight platforms, six of
which were ML platforms.
These were across Intel,
Microsoft, Algorithmia, and now
Twitter.
And out of all
this experience, I
can honestly say that Twitter
pushes the envelope on almost
every boundary.
And it is based
on that experience
that we've seen
some key learnings.
And this include the
increasing importance
of the co-design
of the ML models
and the infrastructure,
both of these,
to have a balance between them.
So when we think of the
end-to-end platform,
it has to strike a balance that
balances out the infrastructure
or technology with the ML and,
ultimately, with the business.
So one of the biggest predictors
for success for a project
has been how well does
the talent understand both
the ML and the infrastructure.
And as a-- for
PMs, additionally,
we also are looking to--
for understanding of the
business and the product
designs-- so base
product designing them.
Some of these things that
we're trying to address
are simplified with our
ML platform in which we
have to track down some of
that infrastructure, where we
make it easier through tools.
We make it flexible and--
so that we can better
focus on the ML,
the building of these models.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Awesome.
That makes a ton of sense.
And I think that's
exactly how we
hope folks are thinking
about the advantages
that Vertex AI can bring
to their organizations.
Matt, can you share
a little bit more
about how Vertex AI
helped with your needs
and how easy it
was to get started?
MATT FERRARI: Sure.
So, so far, to baseline, we've
adopted Vertex AI Workbench
and AI Training components
across the Vertex platform.
Both of those components
have accelerated our adoption
of highly scalable model
development and training
capabilities with a real focus
on are they purpose-built
and at scale for
Wayfair's needs.
We've got really enthusiastic
adoption from our own data
science community.
For example, to put
some numbers behind it,
we rolled out Vertex AI
Workbench a few months ago
and, over a period of 30 days,
already had more than 100 users
on the platform spanning
across 35 projects.
And candidly, it's
growing constantly.
In terms of ease, I would say
that we have an ML platform's
organization that specifically
built accelerators for our data
scientists to adopt
these components easily,
such as integrations into
our internal provisioning
solutions, along with
sample code or automatically
created DAGs that
utilize AI training
platform within
existing Airflow DAGs.
LILLY MCNEALUS: Amazing.
We're so excited to
hear that you're already
having so much success
with Vertex AI Workbench.
And at Google, we're
thrilled to contribute
to the transformational ML
journeys of both Twitter
and Wayfair.
Thank you both so much
for your time today
and for sharing your insights.
And thanks to everyone for
watching and tuning in.